[Musique]
monsieur bonjour n nous vous intervieons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s' aelle Serview nous avons voulu vous
recevoir car vous occupez actuellement
une poste un poste de syndicaliste et
surtout vous travaillez dans la police
et vous travaillez dans quel type de
police et quel type de syndicat je vous
écoute désolé pour la question mais non
je vous écoute donc je travaille donc
pour la CGT police je suis le secrétaire
général depuis quelques mois et sinon je
travaille dans un service de
renseignement qui est le service territ
du renseignement territorial le CELI qui
a pris la suite des renseignements
généraux d'accord alors on va on va vous
faire une question très simple non grade
matricule alors Alexandre Langlois
gardien de la paix et matricule 135 793
gardien de la paix pourquoi gardien de
la paix dans le renseignement ben parce
que vous êtes pas OPJ alors OPJ non dans
OPJ officier de police judiciaire
exactement dans le renseignement
territorial comme chez les anciens RG
tous les collègues qui travaillaient là
n'avaient pas leur perdaient leur
qualification d'OPJ et on ne peut pas
l'avoir pour faire une distinction entre
administratif et judiciaire à
l'exception du temps des RG avait une
petite exception sur les cours et jou
alors ça consiste en quoi le travail de
renseignement territorial renseignement
territorial donc on a repris 90 %
d'émission d' RG qui consiste à j'allis
dire faire un baromètre social un petit
peu pour l'État et le but des missions
c'est de prévoir tous les ce qui
pourrait trouber l'ordre public vous
prenez la température en fait la
température donc sur les manifestations
c'est nous qui compons avec une petite
anecdote pour les collègues parisiens
qui des fois il y a une différence dans
les chiffres par exemple il compte pas
les manifestants sur les trottoirs qui
sont que dépassants dans les autres
départements c'est plus facile et je
vais vous dire je vais vous dire sur le
comptage des manifestants maintenant on
est à l'airre du numérique et grâce à
cette nouvelle loi ça a commencé avec la
loi de programmation militaire mais à la
loi de la loi de renseignement vous
pouvez compter les le le nombre de
téléphones portables sur la zone donc
voilà qu'est-ce que je peux vous poser
comme question concernant votre travail
à l'heure actuelle est-ce que c'est
difficile d'être syndicaliste surtout
travaillant dans le renseignement
territorial alors ça dépend quel
syndicat je il y a beaucoup de
syndicalistes qui se recase après leur
carrière de syndicaliste ils retournent
au service ils prennent un service de
renseignement général par exemple dans
mon service j'ai eu des collègues qui
sont venus du syndicat unitégp par
exemple ou unité ou alliance qui sont
arrivés ici après leur mandat syndical
j'ai fait la démarche inverse j'étais
dans ce service et je suis devenu
syndicaliste parce que je n'avais pas
les moyens de travailler pourquoi vous
avez pas les moyens de travailler alors
moi je suis arrivé au moment de la
réforme juste après la réforme des RG on
était en formation générale à l'époque
et donc c'est Monsieur Sarkozi qui a
lancé cette c'est Monsieur Sarkozi qui a
lancé ça en 2008 la RG ont disparu en
juillet 2008 euh où juin je ne sais plus
enfin un mois après eu et donc la
réforme ce qui s'est passé c'est que le
l'information générale à l'époque donc
déjà perdu le type de renseignement pour
faire information ce qui est déjà une
dégradation dans le dans la sémantique
et ensuite lesissions sont restés à 90 %
pour l'information générale et 10 % sont
partis fusionner avec la DST pour créer
la dcriri sachant que les moyens sont
partis à 60 voire 70 % avec les 10 % des
collègues qui ont rejoint la DCRI du
coup la DC par les parents pauvres en
fait les parents pauvres et en plus de
ça nous étions une direction
indépendante et nous sommes passés sous
la coupe de la sécurité publique qui est
un peu le Fourtout de la police
nationale
ce qui fait que les objectifs sont pas
les mêmes et le moyen de travail ne sont
pas les mêmes et quelle difficulté vous
rencontrez difficulté concrète c'est on
a pas de véhicule en nombre suffisant
quand on a commencé on était trois par
véhicule c'était pas terrible mais
encore ça pouvait aller au fur et à
mesure on a eu des renforcements en
nombre de personnel mais pas en nombre
de véhicules à l'heure actuelle on est
par exemple moi je travaille sur le 78
on est à 4 C fonctionnaires par véhicule
ce qui veut dire que comme on se déplace
c'est à un ou deux il y en a trois qui
ont des TR ou qure qui restent sur le
carreau au bureau avec ce qui s'est
passé en plus récemment on a eu des
coupures Internet ce qui fait que même
quand on est au bureau des fois on a eu
pendant 24 heur une fois coupure
internet on a même pas pu travailler
correctement donc le renseignement
territorial ne fait que d'acquisition de
renseignement sur le terrain pas sur
internet alors normalement le but
c'était de la grosse différence entre
avec la des série qui est devenue djci
c'est que nous nous avons sur le terrain
du renseignement humain j'allais dire
c'est que notre renseignement c'est pas
d'aller faire normalement des de
l'espionnage par écoute téléphonique
poser des caméras nous c'estall voir les
personnes qui nous dis qui nous disent
qui nous renseignent qui nous disent pas
du côté deslation mais par exemple je
prendre un exemple exemple sur une
manifestation moi je suis du côté social
comm une manifestation qui est déclaré
on prend contact avec les organisateurs
le côté en face j'allais dire s'il y en
a un savoir un peu pour mettre un
service d'ordre approprié que le jour de
la manifestation tout se passe bien
qu'on nous dise bah par exemple il y a
tel élément qui est perturbateur qu'on
puisse l'écarter que la manifestation se
déroule correctement et qui est pas une
mauvaise image qui est donnée donc ça
c'est notre rôle donc après on peut
avoir ces informations là quand on
connaît les syndicalistes les chefs
d'entreprise les élus qui peont nous
dire bah tiens j'ai entendu parler qu'il
y aurait tel rassemblement tel
manifestation contact humain contact
humain voilà même chose un petit peu
pour le la surveillance de l'islam de
France et enfin des religions général
mais à l'heure actuelle c'est l'islam de
France où les on a été surtout renforcé
où c'estes contacts avec les
responsablebles de mosquée et cetera
pour rendre contact la température
savoir les prêches qui se disent et
savoir s'il y a pas des éléments qui
seraient un petit peu dissidents ou qui
aurait une un discours dissonnant plus
radical radical j'allais dire pour que
bah on puisse faire lefr faire un
environnement et savoir s'il y a
dangerosité ou pas toujours dans le
principe de faire une limite pour
sécurité des citoyens et liberté
d'expressionement d'accord euh je
voudrais savoir comment vous mettez en
œuvre vos enquêtes et quels sont les
problèmes que votre hiérarchie pourrait
vous poser si c'est sur des dossiers un
petit peu politiques financiers ou des
choses comme ça est-ce que vous avez de
temps en temps des des enquêtes
court-circuité par votre hiérarchie
alors les enfin sur le niveau
renseignement les RG faisait du la
politique jus dans les années jusqu'en
1995 à partir de là ils ont on les a
désaisis du domaine politique ce qui
était un petit peu normal ça coupait ça
avantageait les gens en place au
détriment de l' position à chaque fois
donc ça ça a été terminé après les
dossiers peuvent être concircutés c'est
toujours les chiffres qu'on veut
entendre je vais prendre un exemple euh
pour la manif pour tous par exemple les
services de renseignement en tous les
cas sur le 78 avaient annoncé un chiffre
de manifestants qui allent se déplacer
sur Paris ça a été corrigé par la
hiérarchie qui estimer que ça faisait
trop de monde à envoyer sur Paris pour
le 78 qui est pourtant enfin un
département favorable à la mix pour tous
en général et du coup ils ont baissé les
chiffres le lendemain le Figaro titré en
gros erreur les renseignements
territoriels s'est trompé sur les
chiffres des manif annonce beaucoup plus
de manifestants qu'est-ce qui était là
en ré enfin le gouvernement minimise les
chiffres donc ça ça a été il minimise
les chiffres pour éviter que la que la
PL prenne conscience de tel ou tel type
de mouvement ou l'ampleur de tel ou tel
type de mouvement je pense que c'est
plus pour alors je pourrais pas parler à
la place des politiques tous les cas
c'est dans l'idée qu'on a nous ce qu'on
se fait en tant que collègue sur le
terrain c'est qu'on voit ça c'est que
c'est pour plus faire de
l'accompagnement de la politique du
gouvernement pour transformer les
chifffre dans ce qu'on veut plutôt que
de dire la vérité aux gens c'est pour ça
aussi que les RG sont des fois été mal
venus enfin c'est pareil l'idée on s'est
fait pourquoi ils ont été cassés parce
qu'ils avaient pas leur langue dans leur
poches ils disaient ce qui se passait
plutôt que ce qu'on vous les politiques
voulaient entendre c'estàdire c'est
c'estd l'intégrité de de leur profession
du moins de leur vocation les poussait à
dire la vérité à dire la vérité
au-dessus au bout d'un moment ça
déplaisait je donné un exemple concret
pour qu'on parle sur comment on peut
manipuler les statistiques et les
chiffres c'est pas donc dans le
renseignement c'était au niveau d'un
d'une personne qui a été interpellée par
exemple elle a été interpellée par un
commissariat c'est arrivé dans le nord
de la France interpellé ils ont marqué
un bâton traité ensuite par un autre
service du commissariat qui s'occupait
plus spécialement un autre bâton après
ils ont été récupérés par la police
judiciaire qui a remarqué un même bâton
c'estd que dans les statistiques la même
personne arrêté une fois à compté trois
fois d'accord donc ça c'est pour dire on
a fait bien notre travail et cetera sur
Paris on a des collègues qui se plent on
leur dit il faut par exemple il y a trop
de vol pas de problème les dossiers des
volol passe en dessous et on traite les
autres ce qui a besoin mais c'est qu'en
fait c'est pas qu' a plus c'est la
variable d'ajustement c'est pas qu'il y
en a plus c'est juste qu'ils sont
traités après donc le mois suivant quand
les chiffes sont bons on les remet dans
l'autre sens j'allais donneré enfin j'ai
d'autres exemples quel type de problème
vos collègues vous vous rencontrez en
général est-ce
que la police va bien la police va mal
pourquoi la police va mal parce qu'il y
a une perte de sens du métier il y a
beaucoup de collègues qui sont rentrés
je dire pour caricaturer pour défendre
laorphelin qui sont venus là en disant
pour qu'il a la liberté et la justice
existe l'intérêt général qui existe il
faut des limites on est obligé d'avoir
des limites pour le bien de tous c'est
que chacun puisse s'exprimer et puisse
vivre en collectivité malheureusement
dans les fait c'est plus ça c'est
vraiment des vocations il y a a beaucoup
de vocations après récemment il y a pas
vraiment de planqué là-bas récemment
c'est pas des planqués je dirais c'est
qu'avec la crise et la difficulté de
trouver un emploi il y a des collègues
plus récents qui ont passé plusieurs
concours et qu'pris le premier qu'ils
avaient réussi après à nous de
travailler pour qu'ils aient la vocation
qu'il puissent avancer malheureusement à
l'heure actuelle on est un peu sclérosé
parce que bah on a eu d'abord la
politique du chire qui a été mis en
place donc que personne sait ou personne
ça a fait du mal fctionna aux
fonctionnaires par queils ont perdu un
peu de leur libre arbitre avant on avait
un libre arbitre je dire pour nos
collègues qui mettent les contraventions
et cetera il pouvait adapter soit dire
la personne fallait pas faire ça et
cetera mais il mettait pas forcément la
contravention ou il la mettait suivent
ce qu' il y a plus de rôle pédagogique
il y a plus de rôle pédagogique il est
de moins en moins là pour la simple
raison c'est que maintenant tout est
informatisé il y a plus le contact
humain on veut pression qu'on veut
couper sa la police de sa population
pour qu'ils ai plus de contact donc on a
eu la politique chif qui a été mis en
place par chevinement et amplifié par
Monsieur Sarkozi avec une note qui était
sortie dans un journal àau qui a été
qu'on peut encore trouver sur internet
avec des objectifs chiifffrés à l'époque
on par exemple 83 outrage à agent
c'était ce qui était le plus drôle c'est
comment savoir à l'avance combien il y
aura d'outrage à agent dans l'année donc
impossible donc on se dit en rigolant à
moins de les provoquer qu'est-ce qu'on
fait donc ça c'était le côté ridicule de
la poli du chiffre à laquel on arrivait
ensuite on a eu euh les contraventions
qui ont été gérées par informatique
maintenant c'est on peut faire des
procès de contraventions qui sont
directement en voyés un centre de
gestion sur Renn et tout estort
informatique dire qu'on a plus le
contact avec la personne il y a un petit
côté pédagogique même si on metettait la
contravention pou expliquer ça pour
telle raison telle raison maintenant ça
part on voit même pas la personne et en
plus ça pose un problème parce que
l'informatique dans la police nationale
ou dans l'administration générale est
des fois mal gérée ce qui fait qu'il y a
des gens qui se plaignent d'avoir payé
le contvention leur dit bah écoutez vous
nous faites un recommander à vos frais
pour vous nous expliquer vous l'avez
déjà payé donc la personne sanctionnée
qui a déjà fait entre guillemets qui a
fait unandonorable qui a payé ce qu'elle
devait on lui dit expliquez-vous pour
nous expliquer pourquoi nous on vous en
on on comprend bien que la police va mal
par le fait que bah on on supprime le
contact humain entre quelqu'un qui a
pratiquement donné sa vie pour l'intérêt
général ou qui donne sa vie ou euh son
travail pour l'intérêt général et le
manque de contact on peut le comprendre
ça se manifeste comment tous les jours
vous avez quoi vous avez des dépressions
vous avez des gens agressif vous avez
quoi alors on a des dépressions des
burnout de plus en plus donc c'est quoi
de plus en plus de plus en plus des
chres des chiffres bah sur 30 ans on a
repris les chiffres qui a fait donc il
sont qui été sur un site victime du
devoir qui qui s'appelle et qui a été
repris donc on peut retrouver sur une un
sociologue qui a refait aussi une étude
sur ça pas le nom du du sociologue bon
on le chercher
donc du coup l'enquête montre que depuis
1980 il y a eu à peu près 1450 collègues
qui sont suicidés donc qui ont réussi à
se suicider on parle pas des tentatives
de suicide he qui sont encore plus
nombreuses et en parallèle on a mis le
chiffre suivant qui a eu à peu près 490
collègues qui sont morts du devoir dire
morts à cause des délinquants et de leur
mission c'est dire que la souffrance au
travail a créé quasiment trois fois plus
de mort que les délinquants eux-mêmes
qu'est-ce que ça fait quand vous
apprenez qu'un collègue s'est suicidé
avec son arme de service ben déjà ça
fait toujours tout drôle on se dit
pourquoi on n' pas pu l'éviter comment
c'est arrivé et en général c'est là où
il y a une incompréhension pareil il y a
un fuset qui se creuse même au sein de
la police en
généralérarchie a toujours une enquête
qui dit problème personnel c'est pour ça
ça n'a rien avec le travail et en fait
on va pas plus loin alors c'est c'est
lourd de symbolique quand même de
prendre son arme de service pour se se
mettre une bastos dans le crâne ben
c'est lourd depuis peu grâce au Conseil
d'État maintenant c'est reconnu
d'office comme quoi c'est le service qui
est responsable mais ça une balaille de
long la galeine et surtout c'est que bah
c'est effectivement c'est souvent lié
aux conditions personnelles familiales
mais parce que l'emploi du temps a fait
que les policiers par exemple j'ai donné
un an de travail les policiers en
général travaille en 4 de c'est qu'ils
ont 4 jours travailler de jours de repos
4 jours travailler c'està dire qu'ils
ont un weekend sur 6 qu'ils sont coupés
pas de vie familiale pas de vie
familiale pas de vie associative
possible pour aller faire du sport
régulièrement dans une association est
est-ce qu'il y a des des suicides dans
les familles des des policiers
c'est-à-dire que par exemple les les les
gamins à l'école ne voyant pas leurs
parents bah sont en échec social est-ce
que les les femmes attendant à la maison
sont dépressifs est-ce que vous avez
est-ce que vous avez mené des des études
là-dessus est-ce qu'il y a des chiffres
des statistiques sur les répercussions
de votre travail sur le contexte
familial j'en ai pas j'ai pas vu j'ai
pas cherché en tous les cas sur par
rapport au suicide et conditions de
travail par contre on sait qu'en général
quand il a de plus en plus de famille
maintenant porte plainte en tant que
partie CIVI quand il y a un collègue qui
suicide donc ça de ce côté-là ça montre
à une application et qu'il y a des
choses qui bougent et que par exemple il
y a une cas à Nice il y a un ou 2 ans le
bien sûr a classé c'était fait cause
personnelle problème rien à voir et
finalement enquête a été ouverte et
cetera et à l'heure actuelle on est en
train de se dire que finalement c'était
peut-être le travail quand même qui
était derrière un autre cas où ça c'est
un collègue qui a eu par exemple avec
son cycle de travail il avait garde
alterné pour s son fils il l'avait un
mercredi et un samedi sur deux enfin un
weekend sur de pardon ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'on lui a fait une promesse il y
a un nouveau cycle de travail qui est
très bien que les collègues voudrait
bien qu'il soit généralisé qui 2 jours
de travail 2 jours de repos 3 jours de
travail la semaine suivante on inverse
donc voilà donc le collègue dit c'est
impeccable on lui avait promis ça on lui
a dit thoracique de travail il l'avait
il était parfait il voyait son fils
comme prévu dans le tour de garde il a
demandé à aller dans un autre service on
lui dit écoute tu manges un peu ton pain
noir tu retournes dans l'ancien cycle de
travail d'ici quelques mois entre mai
mais c'était que de l'oral résultat des
cours il voyait plus son fils app par un
weekend surc c'est encore quand ça
tombait le weekend où il était de garde
ce qui fait que son fils Ben il a dit je
veux plus te voir pour Noël et du coup
le collègue qu'est-ce qu'il a fait alors
c'est malheureux hein il a pris il avait
il avait prévu d'aller faire d'ouvrir il
y avait une soirée le soir il a pris une
bouteille il a
il a bu un petit peu il a été du coup
mis en quête administrative pour le
sanctionner on va dire c'est un collègue
alcoolique non en fait il a pourquoi
l'administration fait pas l'effort du
raisonnement dernière alors vous êtes
policier vous êtes syndicaliste vous
cumulez mais vous êtes en train de nous
réconcilier avec les
deux les syndicats dans la police
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils gardent les
mains dans les poches qu'est-ce qu'ils
font quelle est vraiment le leur action
pour aider leur
corporation alors les de police euh on
va faire un petit historque très rapide
la CGT police était le seul syndicat de
police en 1948 il n avait pas d'autres
ça posait un problème au niveau du
gouvernement parce que du coup les CRS
les policiers quand il y avait une
manifestation il disaient bravo les
manifestants posant les matraques qui
n'allait pas du tout au pouvoir en place
du coup ils ont fait rentrer la CFTC
puis au fur à mesure du temps
l'administration a divisé les personnels
en différents syndicats et en
différentes catégories de personnel donc
après ils ont met des syndicats par les
adjoints techniques les adjoints
administratifs les gardiens de l'appel
les officiers et les commissaires comme
ça tout le monde s'opposait dans tous
les sens impeccable euh du coup aussi
donc pourquoi on arrivit là parce que
chez nous les syndicat tiennent en fait
un peu le rôle jeallis dire de DRH c'est
un peu curieux c'est que tout ce qui est
mutation à avancement on doit passer par
le syndicat pourquoi euh dans les textes
il y a des commissions administratives
paritaires cap et ces cap sont donc
comme leur donc l'indique moitié
administration moitié syndicat elles ont
un rôle consultatif et à la base les
syndicats siég pour vérifier que
l'administration ne faisait pas
n'importe quoi au niveau des avancements
et mutations ça s'est transformé en
maintenant les syndicats choisissent un
peu quiils veulent et en échange ils
fichent laapp administration et ça ça s
retourner en fait si on connaît
quelqu'un dans un syndicat qui est bien
placé on aura notre avancement ou notre
mutation plus rapidement et si on n'est
pas dedans B on l'aura pas je parle des
syndicats majoritaire qui siège lesquels
donc nous avons pour les gardiens de la
paix unité GP foo et le côté en de en
parallèle alliance qui est la CF CGC
pour les officiers nous avons le Sssi
qui est ancien snopant C syndicat des
CAD de l'intérieur je plus le nouveau
nom on l'appelle toujours le SNOP et
synergie de l'autre côté qui est le
pendant à la CFCC et les syndicats des
commissaires au-dessus dont je un
syndicat des commissaires de la police
nationale syndicats indépendant des
commissaires de la police nationale euh
donc ça c'est la majoritaire et je je
vous
coupe on entend toujours dire que les
syndicalistes sont corrompus que les
syndicats sont corrompu ce ce ce bruit
de de on dit toujours il y a jamais de
fumé sans feu vous avez entendu du côté
des syndicats de police des magouilles
des choses comme ça ou ben je vais
donner un exemple après je vais pas
porter de jugement ferai jugement
soi-même nous avons eu donc par exemple
pour les officiers nous avons eu le
secrétaire général du syndicat synergie
qui s'était présenté sur les listes pour
devenir conseiller général les listes
UMP voilà à la fin il a été élu donc
très bien mais il ne pouvait pas cumuler
les deux mandat ce nétait pas possible
donc comme c'était pas possible d'être à
la fois policier et à la fois synd enfin
à la fois élu régional monsieur Sarkozi
l'a passé préfet sous-préfet
immédiatement pour pouvoir concilier les
deux un autre exemple nous avons eu
quelqu'un quand que ça peut être
légitime non c'estàdire ça reste un flic
un préfet non un préfet c'est un préfet
c'est un autre corps c'est un autre
corps d'acc c'est la préfecture quelques
commissaires arrivent dans le corps
préfectural à la fin mais c'est c'est le
rêve les commissaires rêveraient d'être
inégré dans ce corps là c'est dire que
c'est le corps auudessus pour eux donc
c'est pas la même pay aussi c'est pas la
même pay c'est plus les c'est plus on n
plus policier PRF à d'autres les
représentants de l'État dans les
départements ord et un autre exemple
donc toujours sur on va rester sur le
corps préfectoral le au niveau donc là
c'était pour les ministères de
l'Intérieur au niveau des adjints
techniques et administratifs il y a le
représentant central de foo donc au
niveau ministère de l'intérieur quand
monsieur Vals a pris ses fonctions en
tant que ministre de l'Intérieur à
l'époque on a fait un réunion avec tous
les syndicats on était encore invité à
l'époque
euh et
euh tout le monde se vous voit monsieur
le ministre et ça arrive donc à ce
fameux syndicaliste donc là C GT a fait
un petit communiqué sur qu'on peut
retrouver sur
internet il a dit ben écoute je suis
content manuel que tu sois là donc c'est
le seul qui a tutoyé et il a fait écoute
parmi nous il y a des gens qui
mériteraient d'être préfet quand même
par rapport à leur investissement dans
le syndicat donc sur le moment manuel
vas l' recadré en disant écoutez on se
vous voit il y a pas de tout ça ce qui
était drôle par contre un an après le
même personne passait sous-préfet et été
nommé par Manuel Vals le hasard le
hasard on nous a dit que c'était pour
service rendu et et parce que vous vous
vous vous vous semblez insinuer que la
carte
politique permettrait de d'avoir de
l'avancement c'est ça bah si en
caricature en général il y a deux côtés
chez nous il y a majoritaire il y a effo
qui est plutôt dit de gauche parce que
ils ont mangé l'UNA et de l'autre côté
il y a la cfcgc qui est plutôt droite
quand il y a un gouvernement de droite
bah c'est plutôt la CF CGC qui avance et
quand c'est plutôt de gauche et faut qui
avance les exemples qu'on a mais après
ils arrivent tous aussi à se mettre
d'accord pour le calme dans le pour
qu'il y ait pas de vague je vais donner
un autre exemple c'est que par exemple
de Lage monsieur de Lage Jean-Claude
deage responsable national donc
d'alliance pour les gardiens de la paix
et rulp donc c'est responsable d'unité
locale donc rulp en fait c'est un grade
entre guillemets qu'on peut avoir que
quand on occupe une fonction il occupe
aucune fonction de terrain il encadre
personne il est responsable syndical
donc on a posé la question n'a pas eu de
réponse ceci c'est valable pour son
homologue de Force Ouvrière SGP foo
unité qui a la même chose par contre
donc comme c'était la droite qui était
au pouvoir à l'époque où il l'a eu lui
en plus il a la Légion d'Honneur on
demande pour quelle raison il a la
Légion d'Honneur quel fait d'arme il a
fait descollè tous les jours qui
risquent leur vie qui vont sauver des
gens dans les flammes qui voilà qui sont
dans les attentats enfin ils ont pas la
Légion d'honneur au m ils ont une
médaille du mérite quand c'est de temps
en temps et lui il a eu la Légion
d'Honneur donc on se pose des questions
enfin onffirme rien c'est c'est c'est
compliqué quand même d'être policier au
21e siècle la
population un petit peu de rencœur face
la police la police souffre la police
est de moins en moins reconnu c'est
compliqué hein ah vous un gardien de la
p ça gagne combien un gardien de la p ça
gagne en début de carrière 1600 € net
net en région parisienne desésavantages
en nature logement de
fonction non crèche une mutuelle
spéciale quelque chose non on a des
mutuels police voilà qui en général le
ministère permet d'avoir des collègues
qui sont détachés pour s'en occuper donc
mais c'est pas un avantage qu'on a
chacun c'est juste un avantage au niveau
de la mutuelle en général et après au
niveau des places pour le logement faut
demander à la préfecture donc on passe
par la préfecture donc on est dans un
circuit fonctionnaire général pas
spécialement mais avec quelque chose de
toute façon de particulier où les
collègues en général refuse c'est que
les logements préfecture qui sont
proposés sont dans les zones où ils ont
arrêté quelqu'un le matin j'allais dire
compliqué donc c'est compliqué donc
général c'est refusé enfin les gens
disent ben je vais pas le prendre et et
et dans le renseignement territorial ça
commence à combien pareil en fait c'est
c'est la fonction publique c'est la même
c'est la grille de salaire fonction
publique a pas de Ch plus d' si si je
veux acheter un policier il faut que je
lui propose plus de 1600 € par mois
c'est ça c'est compliqué d'acheter un
policier pour ceux qui sont vertueux
après les autres je pourrais pas dire
c'est il y a de la corruption dans la
police maintenant bah la corruption je
dire c'est tout le monde lit les
journaux c'est je vais pas dire le
contraire c'est c'est par exemple je
reprendffaire Ikea où il y a des fiches
stick qui ont été donné pour VF c'est
combien pour avoir une fiche du stick il
faut payer combien ben moi je peux pas
dire j'ai pas de prix
d'accord qu'est-ce que je peux vous
poser d'autre comme question un petit
peu
toch vous avez vous avez assisté à des
choses vraiment dramatiques dans votre
profession où des des collusions étaient
importantes alors je vais donner un
exemple par rapport au renseignement
comme ça c'est tous les ans par exemple
sur il y a le MF qui fait son université
d'été tous les ans il y a la police qui
assure la sécurité de l'université d'été
du
meddeef tous les ans enfin tous les cas
maintenant met plus dans la Bou du coup
parce que j'ai trop ouvert ma bouche
tous les
vous avez trop fait votre travail
peut-être peut-être un moment en fait
jusqu'à 2 ans en tous les cas maintenant
à priori je j'ai refa un track dessus on
m'a pas affirmé le contraire le MF
demande de passer tous les intérimaires
qu' vont avoir au fichier pour savoir à
qui ils ont affaire à qui vont
embaucher de façon illégal c'estd parce
que pour passer quelqu' fichier des
fonctionnaires donc une demande
officielle faite par l'organisateur qui
demande à la préfecture à la police
nationale on jamais su à qui mais ENF ça
arrive jusqu'à nous demande de passer au
fichier avec une listing tous les noms
des gens qui travaillent pour le MF sur
l'événement alors que normalement pour
passer quelqu'un fichier c'est encadré
par la loi c'est pour une enquête
administrative pour naturalisation
papier enfin ce qu'on veut une enquête
judiciaire en cours pareil ou alors
quand une personne se déplace dans un
ministère où il y a une personnalité
mais c'est la personne qui vient dans un
lieu sensible j'allais dire qu parce que
là le MDEF nous a notre hiérarchie nous
a dit que c'est parce que comme des
ministres se déplac au MDF pour leur
sécurité il faut passer tout le monde au
fichier alors que légalement c'est que
si les gens les ministre reçoiv ou les
personnalités reçoivent chez dans les
locaux sécurisés qu'on le fait donc on n
pas eu de réponse pour le moment de
savoir quel motif légal on a demandé un
ord d'écrit qu'on a jamais eu on nous a
dit on fait ça comme ça par oral entre
service c'est normal à l'ancienne à
l'ancienne
et sur place il y a une compagnie de CRS
qui est présente nous qui faisons la
protection des personnalités donc quand
elles sont là c'est normal c'est notre
travail par contre qu'on fasse le
filtrage en l'entrée c'est moins normal
est-ce qu'il y a une privatisation de la
police maintenant al tion de la police
on pourrait dire oui parce qu'il y a des
textes des circulaires qui sont passés
pour permettre de d'acheter un policier
pour un événement j'allais dire pour
Assur sécurité un policier le louer
peut-être le louer ouais j'ai mal le mot
était mal à propos enfin le louer
d'ailleurs non c'est l'administration
qui met à disposition combien on le loue
le policier le loup bah on a découvert
ça donc il y a c'est c'est fait par
c'est un contrat qui est évalué à chaque
fois mais on a un exemple du Tour de
France qui un événement privé et le tour
de franceou un policier environ 11 € et
un gendarme environ 12 €. après il y a
le détail combien vaut un cône en
plastique à mettre les motards c'est
plus cher et cetera et le Parisien est
fait un article détaillé sur ça et qui
qui paye le gardien de la paix ou qui
paye le gendarme c'est une facture qui
estmise c'est l'administration qui paye
c'est directement le Tour de France qui
paye comment ça se passe alors c'est
l'administration qui touche l'argent oui
et les collègues sur le terrain n'en
voient pas la couleur ils ont pas de
défraimment pour ça on m a des collègues
plus anciens qui m'ont raconté qu'à
l'époque ils assuré d'émissions à tel
titre ils avaient un petit bonus de
quelques nombre de Frans à l'époque mais
depuis il y a plus de il y a plus ça non
plus alors la question qu'on avait posé
c'est que pendant ce tempsl est-ce que
les citoyens ont une réduction sur leurs
impôts vu que la police n'est plus
utilisé à protection de tous mais pour
un événement privé pareil on n' pas eu
de réponse on va on va changer de sujet
on va aborder la loi de renseignement
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de
renseignement bah c'est encore jeis dire
un peu la communication d'un côté parce
qu'il y a des éléments par exemple je
peux expliquer que le renseignement
territorial il déjà des services qui
sont pas utilisés à leur plein potentiel
lequel le renseignement orial nous à
l'heure actuelle ce qu'on constate c'est
que les gens qui sont malinttentionnés
j'avais dire on va dire des
pseudoterroristes ou des gens qui
voudraient commettre un attentat
maintenant ils font plus par Internet
ils ont plus des téléphones qui gardent
en ligne fixe maintenant ils vont se
mettre au fond des caves ils payent en
liquide pour savoir cette information là
c'est pas des gadgets technologie qui
vont permettre de savoir où ils sont ça
va être forcément des sur l'ffire
Coulibali quand même ils sont passés par
Internet pour communiquer non oui il y
en a mais c'est pas la majorité ceux
qu'on va attraper c'est dire les mauvais
d'accord les pas organisés d'accord et
la deuxième volet donc par contre c'est
le côté des libertés c'est qu'on veut
nous faire vendre une loi pour la
protection contre le du terror enfin
pour lutter contre le terrorisme et
après il y a toutes les autres choses
qui sont derrière vous votre avis euh
c'est le r le rigne le renseignement de
terrain c'est la clé de compréhension du
terrorisme c'est-à-dire on peut prendre
correctement la température grâce au
renseignement de terrain sans se barder
d'un organe législatif qui encadre
vraiment la l'aspect numérique bah la
première étape c'est de se dire on sait
pas ce que ça pourrait donner parce
qu'on le fait pas on utilise pas le
service à son pleat potentiel donc si on
le sait pas on peut pas pourquoi
commencer par faire une en disant ça
fonctionne pas ou alors on sait qu'on a
fait en sorte de que ça fonctionne pas
pour pouvoir faire la loi est-ce que
vous avez une petite idée de combien ça
va nous coûter cette fameuse loi il y a
des estimations que j'ai plus en tête
très cher on peut trouver de l'argent
pour faire les choses qu'on veut mais il
y a un business là-dedans est-ce qu'il y
a des prestataires extérieurs qui se
sont mis par exemple sur les boîtes
noires chez les opérateurs ou des choses
comme ça vous savez pas pas la moindre
idée je sais juste que pour les écoutes
téléphoniques ou il y avait des relevés
il y a des les opérateurs demandent de
qui n'ont jamais été payé d'ailleurs je
crois bien je une boî a une boîte qui
est en difficulté parce que l'État ne
payait pas donc pour vous la loi de
programmation la loi la loi casenuve est
contreproductive B si elle devait
intervenir déjà bien trop tôt parce
qu'on a pas tout utilisé deuxièmement
comme tuas fait le lapsus il y avait la
loi de programmation militaire qui
permet déjà de faire les choses dessus
qui est passé aussi de façon anonyme et
personne n a parlé à l'époque quasiment
et là on va étendre ça surtout des
services civil donc ça veut dire des
gens normalement qui peuvent parler à
différence des militaires qui doivent
garder le qui doivent se
taire donc ensuite c'est aussi le
problème de cette loi c'est que tout est
flou le flou c'est bah il y a dedans il
y a marqué alors j'ai plus les TER exact
mais on pourra sil a des attroupements
violents il y aura les intérêts
économiques de la France il y aura il y
a plein de choses qui n'ont rien à voir
avec le terrorisme et qui sont pas
définis non une loi c'est carré on dit
voilà il y a tel élément ça peut arriver
de vant un juge et on dit ça fait ça je
veux dire quand quelqu'un vole il sait
qu'il va avoir tant temps les peines
sont temp et ça donne conclusion il a
fait ça et c'est ce qui risque là on
sait pas ce qu'on risque parce qu'on
sait pas ce qu'on doit faire ou pas
faire déjà à la base ce qui fait que
tout flux jgique juridique pardon
entraîne un arbitraire je vais faire une
petite chronologie en amont c'est que
Monsieur Vals quand il était ministre
d'intérieur a changé le code de
dotologie chez nous le code deontologie
en faisant donc la droite avait prévu de
leur faire à l'époque donc c'était
monsieur gant mais c'était un toilettage
c'était on changait de tris mots c'était
pas terrible mais c'était du la Tage
pour fêter les 30 ans là ils ont tout
refait et du coup à l'intérieur ils ont
pris des disp du code de la fonction
publique de Vichi ou le fonctionnaire
même dans sa vie privée du coup le code
de fonctionnement de Vichi de la
fonction publique de Vich de la fonction
publique de Vichy où le fonctionnaire à
l'époque devait même dans sa vie privée
faire attention à la à l'honneur de
l'institution et à rien faire pour aller
contre les institutions moi je travaille
de telle heure à telle heure dans ma vie
privée tant que je travaille pas un
secret professionnel le secret
professionnel sur des affaires sur des
noms sur des nom de personne que je
pourrais avoir des informations ENF dans
ma vie privée je peux avoir les opinions
et ce que je veux donc maintenant il y a
grâce à ce code deentologie enfin grâ
c'est ironique he un fonctionnaire doit
faire preuve de loyauté de discernement
et tout ça même dans sa vie privée ce
qu'on carécuturant n on a fait un petit
trac en disant bah le lundi matin on
tourne la machine à café ça va être
sympa je vais pas me raconter mon
weekend de peur qu'on me dise bah
qu'est-ce que tu as fait ah mais ça tu
avais pas le droit de le faire on doit
vérifier son entourage et son entourage
de son entourage avec qui on parle et
cetera donc on arrive à faire des
enquêtes de proximité directement chez
vous quoi chez nous et en disant surtout
le but c'est de pouvoir nous sanctionner
faire peur parce que le discernement ce
qu'on nous a expliqué on a une petite
formation de sensibilisation au code de
déontologie et on avait moi je posé la
question disant mais en fait déjà un
code de déontologie vu que c'est limite
les liberté çaurait du pris par une loi
tout ce qui limite les liberté c'est la
loi pas un décret on m'a dit on n'est
pas là pour juger la légalité des
décisions du minist à l'intérieur ben je
suis tatillon parce que comment faire
respecter les libertés pour les autres
quand chez nous on les a pas
respecté deuxème chose après comment
être au service de la population c'est
aussi ça qu'on a mis en en avant c'est
il y a deux conceptions pour la police
nationale je crois que c'est là tout le
débat de à quoi sert la police nationale
il y en a un c'est la police nationale
créée par Vichy qui dit au service du
gouvernement du patronat et cetera pour
contrôle social de la population vous
pensez vraiment que cette loi c'est pour
le contrôle social de la population je
sais pas si c'est pour ça mais ça peut
le permettre ça peut le permettre et
c'està-dire que tout le monde est écouté
pour le dans la loi de façon il y a qui
peut décider dans la loi d'écouter qui
c'est le premier ministre après avis
d'une commission consultative donc
consultatif c'estd que même s'ils disent
non il pourra quand même le faire et
après il marqué sauf urgence urgence à
l'appréciation il y a pas d'appréciation
c'est l'appréciation du Premier ministre
donc il pourra dire c'est tout le temps
de l'urgence je met sur écoute qui je
veux comme je veux et ça peut être servi
donc une fois qu'il y a plus de
contrôle dictature de basse indensité on
pourrait dire ça on peut y arriver en
tous les cas on se ramène vers des gens
qui devraient relire an arent des choses
comme ça sur les origines du
totalitarisme parce que c'est on peut
nous dire on le fera pas on s'en servira
pas mais quand il y a possibilité d'abus
un jour il sera fait fait pas forcément
par les personnes en place mais une
autre personne qui viendra derrière
pourra s'en
servir vos collègues
euh en parlent un petit peu entre eux où
il y a pas du tout de de de d'échang de
critique sur cette loi est-ce que vous
qui entre guillemets le la femme de
ménage de la politique étrangère
française c'est-à-dire que on a une
politique étrangère qui est très
agressive ou qui est perçue comme
agressive à l'étranger qui nous amène
des répercussions vous êtes amenés à
gérer ça euh
entre vous vous voyez bien que les
signaux fable de la politique étrangère
française sont au rouge vous allez être
confronté directement à ces menaces en
en première ligne c'est c'est vous êtes
le pompier le le le pompier mais en bleu
euh vos collègues ils perçoivent ça
comment alors pour le renseignement
territorial nous on doit faire
l'environnement d'abord et si jamais on
voit qu'il y a quelque chose on passe ça
à DGSI donc déjà nous on aura pas la fin
mot de l'histoire on doit s'occuper que
ce qui est institutionnel normalement et
faire les repérages vousvez quelle
formation pour faire ça la formation
c'est on doit passer le concours de
gardien de la paix ou officier souvent
le grade ou commissaire on arrive et
après on est pris sur entretien vous
avez vous avez quel background avant de
rentrer comme gardien de la paix moi
j'ai travaillé dans le privé avant j'ai
fait plein de petits boulots au niveau
des études vous au niveau des études
j'ai un doc de droit une licence de
scienceces politiqu mais c'est pas le
cas de tous mes collègues qui ont enfin
c'est variable il y a des gens qui ont
des bacs plus 5 d'autres qui ont que le
bac d'autres à l'époque qui avait pas le
bac mais qui av une culture général
développé qui avait appris par eux-même
donc s'il y a tous les profils du MO
jeux dire il faut savoir être intéressé
partout curieux avoir le contact des
gens et savoir écrire c'est les bases du
métier de renseignement j'allais dire
c'est c'est vraiment les les bases donc
pour revenir à cette loi le fait le fait
queos vos collègues pour revenir à cette
question personne n'en parle dans vos
servic on en parle pas mais il y a non
on en parle pas beaucoup parce qu' déjà
on a l'habitude et encore plus avec le
nouveau code de dontologie bah de
maintenant on peut se faire sanctionner
pour tout et n'importe quoi donc du fait
vous avez vraiment été mis au pas bah au
pas oui parce que je vais donner un
exemple d'un collègue qu' avait mis sur
sa page Facebook qui est une page
facebook je précise qu'il avait
verrouillé pour que ses connaissances y
a accès il avait traité le président de
flambi président Hollande un de ses
contacts a repris la page Facebook et a
refait le
commentaire et donc lui il a été enquête
administrative pour dire que ben écoutez
vous manquez de loyauté en les
institutions vous remettez en cause la
fonction présidentiel qu' a pas rendu
publique pas dans le cadre de ses
fonctions il a pas marqué qu'il est
policier sur sa page Facebook mais
l'administration avait retenu que bah
ses collègu il y a des gens qui sachent
qu'il est savent qu' poli police
surveille la police bah il y a quelqu'un
qui peut surveiller on a le service
interne d'enquête nous he on a les GPN
et car les BF carot c'est ça c'est ça
qui sont la nation toujours je sais plus
ils sont je sais plus où ils sont j'ai
oublié d'ord j'ai suis aller les voir
l'autre jour mais justement pour un
problème de violation de la vie privée
d'un collègue qui avait on est qui
auditionné aussi pareil parce que par
des techniques d'interception de Ty même
pas alors là j'a même pas c'est il a été
enfin ce qui est l'enquête c'est un
problème de couple sa femme passer le
mot de passe de son ordinateur et cetera
toujours est-il que ce qui a été
présenté elle a envoyé des mails qui lui
avait envoyé à échange prix avec
d'autres personnes elle les a donné les
GPN il a été auditionné sur C mail
qu'elle avait obtenu de façon
frauduleuse d'accord sur son
comportement dans sa vie privée qui ne
met en rien en cause la police sur la
sur la loi de
renseignement qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous cibler comme point comme coin comme
point qui pourrait être douloureux par
exemple là là j'ai vu récemment que
l'Allemagne avait voté parce que
l'Allemagne est en train de passer
sensiblement la même chose comme le
Québec le Canada en Allemagne il garde
les informations les les les
métadonnées 2 semaines sur sur notre loi
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il y ait un
limite de temps qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez alors il y a pas de limite de
temps pour le moment enfin je l'ai pas
vu sinon et la limite de temps de toute
façon je vais prendre l'exemple du
fichistick qui doit être mis à jour
régulièrement pour être il est pas mis à
jour parce qu'il y a pas de personnel
pour le faire ou mais là ça va être fait
par un algorithme c'estd qu'on va
remplacer la personne qui fait la mise à
jour on va la remplacer par un petit
robot est-ce que vous pensez que
maintenant la police est en train de
faire sa mutation et ce sont les robots
qui vont avoir le rôle de policier
c'està-dire que vous nous avez décrit en
début d'informat en début de d'interview
qu' avit plus de contact humain est-ce
que c'est à vous à votre avis les les
prémisses de de cette session de contact
entre la police et la population
c'est la suite c'est la suite parce
qu'on a déjà eu les contrventions on a
eu la prèsplainte en ligne et on
continue de dématérialiser tout contact
avec la police et tout ce qu'on pourra
apporter à la population et un lien que
il va plus y avoir ce que bah tout sera
fait par informatique mais encore s'il y
a plus de contact avec la population on
a BO avoir tous les objets les gadgets
technologiques on les met où hormis le
fait que ils vont pouvoir intercepter
tous les mails qu'ils veulent avec des
mots clés bon là s'il y aura pas
personne ça ciblera dans le tas je
trouve que c'est un aspect quand même
positif pour une fois le gouvernement va
écouter les Français et écoutter sur
quoi bah écouter leur opinion par
rapport à quoi par rapport à c toi sur
le renseignement non c'était une boutade
dans le sens pour écouter ou ce qu'il
pensentement ah oui d'accord oui on va
arriver àan à la française comme ça il
ils sauront ce qu'ils pensent et puis je
le truc si jamais les programmes
politiques vont pas faudra changer le
peuple quoi pas changer le programme
c'est c'est c'est quand même lourd de de
de conséquence que vous dites c'est
c'est une NSA à la française avec les
les abuc la NSA appu effectué depuis ces
ces années est-ce que vous pensez que la
France sera mieux lotie peut-être grâce
à ses fonctionnaires un petit peu ce
qu'on a dit tout à l'heure s'il y a
possibilité d'abus il y en aura
forcément il y en a malheureusement déjà
pour le moment qu'on peut encore
sanctionner là il y a pas de il y a pas
de contrôle en fait Sant qu'il y a pas
de contrôle et limite je vois pas
pourquoi on pourrait pas aller dans le
mur nous aussi tout simplement par
exemple on nous a dit le contrôle du
juge c'est trop compliqué trop compliqué
pourquoi ben c'est ce que nous a dit
c'est ça marche pas les juges n'ont pas
les moyens de travailler correctement
les affaires sans pile donnons des la
justice de pvoir contrôler travail de la
poli est vous connaissez le budget de la
justice en France non c'est moins que
l'écologie voilà je juste qu'on est très
mauvais au niveau de l'Europe au niveau
des procédures au niveau des entretiens
des tribunaux et C mais alors là je ne
savais pas une justice performante
nécessite un budget performant si on
baisse les les critères du moins
d'acquisition de de budget pour la
justice c'est qu'il a peut-être une
raison bon ça c'est une appréciation ple
personnelle je vais vous poser deux
trois dernières
questions V pré tion est-ce que vous
avez des conseils à nous donner pour
améliorer les choses ou bah déjà
diffuser l'information de ce qui va se
passer ou parce que quand le
gouvernement pose une question ou
quelques personnes posent une question
si la question est mal posée les gens
vont donner la réponse attendue dire
qu'on nous dit c'est une loi contre le
terrorisme on pose la question est-ce
que vous voulez faire une loi pour
lutter contre le terrorisme la réponse
est automatiquement oui enfin à Mo un
dangereux terroriste mais sinon c'est
oui maintenant si on dit toute cette loi
va permettre aussi de vérifier votre vie
privée on va pouvoir filtrer vos mails
sans que vous le sachiez va pouvoir me
mettre sous écoute ce sera que dans les
mains du Premier ministre et ça va pas
lutter que contre le terrorisme quelle
sera la réponse de la population je suis
pas sûr que ce soit la même donc déjà
diffuser la le vrai contenu de cette loi
ça ne plus utiliser la nove langue voilà
utilisons les vrais mots hein comme
disait quelqu'un ça ne sert à rien de
faire des jeux de mots parce que les
mots n'ont plus de sens hein oui les
mots ont un sens et en enlevé rajoute de
la misère au monde euh une dernière
question une avant-dernière question
euh si ouis peut-être une dernière
question si vous aviez à a laissé un
conseil aux jeunes
générations ah avant ça avant ça avant
ça vous conseillez les les jeunes
générations de devenir policier j'allais
dire dans l't actuel des choses sils ont
un esprit combattant quis sont prêts à
le garder c'est-à-dire prêt à subir la
PR la pression et avancer moi j'ai un
copain qui était rentré dans la poliiss
un moment un copain d'enfance il m'a dit
rentre pas bon je suis
rentré et en fait c'était pas du tout il
il m'avait prévenu que c'était pas
l'image idéalisée que j'en avais qui
aurait une hiérarchie avec une chape de
plomb et qu'on devrait faire comme on
nous dit et qu'on pourrait pas faire
notre travail pour l'intérêt public et
général maintenant si on a une volonté
de faire les textes de loi continent de
protéger ils ont pas encore changé les
textes de loi qui nous permettent de
faire notre travail correctement il
suffit d'avoir la volonté par qu'il
travaille que sur des coutumes on a
toujours fait comme ça voilà par exemple
jeais reprendre un exemple très bien et
pour ça que je parle ce soir
tranquillement en plus d'être
syndicaliste c'est que beaucoup de
collègues oublient que on nous oppose on
a le droit de réserve c'est ce qu'on
nous met mais le droit de réserve n'a
jamais été caractérisé est le droit ou
le devoir le devoir de réserve pardon
excuse-moi le devoir de réserve qui n'a
jamais été qualifié juridiquement c'est
une invention on comprend bien le secret
professionnel pas donner des
informations par contre le devoir de
réserve à part critiquer les
institutions quand quelque chose va pas
je vois pas à ce que ça pourrait
correspondre par contre dans la loi de
83 qui sur la fonction publique chaque
fonctionnaire a un devoir d'information
du public et ça c'est dans la loi c'est
pas dans un décret c'est un devoir
d'informer le public comment ça va parce
que le service public appartient à la
population et ça ils l'ont pas encore
changé et quand les collègues prendront
ça en compte je veux dire ça avancera
déjà beaucoup
mieux si la nous nous on traite un petit
peu les questions un petit peu
économiques géopolitiques géostratégiqu
on voit on voit la
situation un petit peu devenir exécrable
partout dans le monde économiquement
parlant j'ai une question un peu
personnelle à vous poser si la situation
se dégrade que la température de la
population augmente fortement si la
fièvre commence à à parcourir la
population est-ce que vous pensez que la
police prendra le côté des manifestants
j'aimerais bien qu'il soit au service de
l'intérêt général à l'heure actuelle je
sais
pas dernière question si vous aviez
laisser un conseil aux jeunes
générations bah allez voir vos policiers
hein discutez avec eux pendant que vous
pouvez encore et vous verrait que c'est
pas les mêmes personnes que ce qu'on
peut voir à la télé parce que on monre
toujours les mauvais exemples ceux qui
nous cassent les pieds c'est forcément
j'ai un pas de chance ça arriver à des
gens même à des collègues qui sont fait
contrôler par d'autres personnes la
bêtise est malheureusement ce qui are
plus répandu donc donc à défaut que le
gouvernement nos collègues a le courage
parce qu'ils sont tenus par les
règlements comme ils peuvent pas aller
vers vous venz vers eux un peu comme ça
s'est passé quand il y a eu les
manifestations soutien à Charlie Hebdo
où tout le monde est venu vers la police
et ça c'était bien parce que les
policiers ont pris confiance et ils ont
pas oublié ce jour-là en tous les cas de
qui de ils étaient au service de qui
est-ce que vous pensez pas que la loi de
renseignement c'est légaliser déjà des
pratiques existantes alors ça va
légaliser une partie des pratiques
existantes qui était effectivement pour
moi déjà des écoutes administratives
ciblé sur une personne sur telle
personne avec un motif et on pouvveit
contrôler encore la différence qu' va y
avoir là ça va pas être à contre
individuel c'est un contrôle de masse
qui va être légalisé qui n'est pas du
tout le cas à l'heure actuelle un
contrôle de masse c'estd qu'on va
pouvoir intercepter tout avec des comme
on expliqué tout à l'heure des des mots
clés et cetera qui vont être envoyés sur
une personne AC qu'on connaitid au début
et on va commencer à se renseigner sur
parce qu'elle a fait telle recherche dit
t mot au téléphone que vous vous vous
allez avoir un filtrage de masse avec le
filtrage des comportements
que habitudes quand il y aura un mot sur
internet ils pouront le filtrer en
disant je sais pas tiens bombe ils vont
regarder la personne pourquoi elle dit
bombe et une personne par exemple bombe
je passe à ça parce que dans le milieu
du cheval c'est un casque la personne
n'aura rien à voir je pas une
conversation privée dans le milieu du
cheval mais par exemple que il y aura eu
le mot bombe elle va être mise dans un
fichier et par exemple dans le langage
vidéo on dit shooter pour faire prise de
vue imaginez-vous si on devait
interviewer un ministre on pourrait dire
au téléphone entre nous on va choter un
ministre voilà donc comme ça va être
informatisé ça va
être faux positif ben on sait pas ce
qu'il y aura il y aura plein de choses
il y aura tout n'importe quoi et c'est
surtout un contrôle de masse qui est pas
individuel et c'est ça ce qui change
c'est vraiment la grosse différence un
contrôle généralisé plutôt qu'un
contrôle ciblé autant ciblé on peut
encoreevoir des recours auprès de
l'acnine et ceteraant un contrôle de
masse comment pouvo savoir avoir un
recours quelconque parce que même les
organismes de contrôle seront pas
consultés avant de terminer cette
interview je vais vous laisser le micro
je vais laisser le micro dis semblance
ce nouveau média qui vient de se créer
sur Inter inter net on vous laisse deux
questions à poser à monsieur Alexandre
Langlois syndicaliste travaillant en
renseignement territorial
ok merci alors nous on a un média pour
les 15 20 ans 15 25 ans la génération Z
et on s'aperçoit que toute la génération
Z donc des 15 25 ans sont absolument pas
au courant de de ce que c'est est-ce que
ça représente réellement la loi de
renseignement donc est-ce que vous
pourriez nous dire
clairement qu'est-ce qui va qu'est-ce
enfin en quoi ça consiste alors
clairement dans l'état actuel des choses
en caricaturant maximum le Premier
ministre peut mettre sur écoute qui veut
filmer qui veut et prendre des
renseignements et infiltrer les mails de
qui Il veut et en quoi en quoi c'est
dangereux d'avoir tous ces fichiers là
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en faire si ça
tombe dans les mains de quelqu'un de
dangereux qu'est-ce qui peut qu'est-ce
qui peut arriver rien que déjà sur les
opinions politiques jeallis dire par
exemple un gouvernement qui un Premier
ministre qui a des peut regarder ce que
pensent ses adversaires savoir comment
il s'organise déjà rien que
politiquement il on un avantage énorme
sur les autres après il peut aussi
filtrer sur niveau niveau du monde
économique en disant bah tiens telle
société fait c fait ça bah ça donne un
avantage pour ses amis pour les donner
je veux dire tant qu'il y a pas de
contrôle de contrepouvoir pour contrôler
la volonté finalement d'une personne ce
pas que sur des dérives même si la
personne en place le fait pas il y aura
quelqu'un d'autre après lui qui pourra
le mettre en place et est-ce que les les
informations que va collecter l'état
vont être vendu ou est-ce qu'elles
pourront peut-être être enfin est-ce
qu'ils vont se ils vont la jouer comme
ça ou pas alors ça on sait pas par
contre on a déjà un précédent pour le
fichier des cartes grises ils ont déjà
vendu ça à des sociétés privées en
prétex ant que ça allait plus vite dans
les les préfectures étaient surchargé à
l'époque on avait fait un petit article
personne nous au sauf le Figaro ce qui
était amusant
et mais donc du coup des sociétés
privées c'estd que ça fait deux choses
l'une un c'est dire que les gens qui ont
accès à un service public normal en
préfecture pour leur quat grise ils
doivent attendre plus longtemps que des
gens qui vont payer pour avoir accès
dans une société privée à deux vitesses
à deux vitesses en fonction du de
l'argent qu'on a voilà on a plus tous é
Go devant le service public deuxième
chose c'est que les fichiers vendus aux
boîtes privées bah une fois qu'ell l'ont
elles l'ont hein avec les adresses les
nom les gens ell peuvent leur vendre ell
peuvent en faire ce qu'elles veulent
même si sigent une charte on saura
jamais ce qui a été fait derrière donc
on a déjà un précédent pour les cartes
grises donc on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
pourront faire par la suite Alexandre
Langlois je vous remercie un plaisir
[Musique]